hallo liebe zu sehr zu hause wir sind am
freitag angekommen eine harte
trainingswoche liegt hinter uns wir
haben gestern im military
fitnesstraining wirklich körperlich
einiges von euch ab verlangt heute daher
ein regenerationstraining ein aus
lockern ein denen um dann doch wieder
mit einer bisher energisch starten zu
können wir da gary die nici und ist
peter wir begleiten euch wieder durch
das programm und sind vielleicht die
nächste halbe stunde da macht es mit
nutzt die chance und ihr gesagt los
geht's passt auch zum regenerieren auch
um entsprechend aus zu lockern muss sie
den körper ab diese aufwärmen die
muskulatur warmmachen damit beginnen wir
wieder gleichstand lauf locker in
schwung bringen die muskulatur erwärmen
weil eine warme muskulatur den sie
wesentlich schöner und leichter als wir
ganz kräuter muskulatur auch da der
stand laufen ist einmal ein guter start
man kann aber dann gerne variieren mit
an fersen mit dem bahnhof alles in dem
bereich der möglich
ok dann gehen wir gerne in eine
kreisbewegung dass wir kreisen mit den
armen vorwärts große kreise marken genau
und große kreise rückwärts nicht eine
frage haben die spürst du was vom
gestrigen merkert ja muskulär gibt es
irgendwas was da am meisten weh tut oder
sagt wissen was der große gesetz muss
mit oder meisten wir den haben wir mit
dabei beim denen also dass wir haben
dann auch versuchen entsprechend
auszuloggen
ok probieren jetzt einmal klar kleine
koordinative komponente mit hinein zu
bringen indem man eine herren vorwärts
und eine rückwärts kreisen am
einfachsten ist es waren hier oben
beginnt und aus der oberen positionen
dann die hände einfach runterfallen
lassen und dann geht es in wahrheit
schon los ist mal klar ist natürlich
nicht so einfach wenn man das nicht so
gut kann wir trainieren das natürlich
öfters ok auslagern oberkörpern wir
laufen wieder ganz kurz am stand da kann
man natürlich auch wieder variieren so
wie man die ganze woche gemacht haben
mit dem boxer lauf mit handball männer
springen verschiedenste möglichkeiten
einfach um den körper die muskulatur
vorzubereiten
genau
ich sage die bewegung ist da ganz
wichtig um den körper entsprechend
vorzubereiten
aber bleiben wir widerstehen oberkörper
in die vorbeugen und die die ganze woche
dabei waren wissen schon was kommt eine
rotation garrett einmal vor genau 5
drehen in der vorbeugung geht schon los
da kann man mit kleinen bewegungen
anfangen und dann immer größer werden
die den radius immer weiter machen gerne
und wieder locker laufen
hier gibt es irgendwas bei dir muskulär
was da weder von gestern oder hast es
gut verdaut kurz darauf trainiert sehr
gut passt ok versucht name kapitel das
tempo zu variieren beim laufen das heißt
einmal kurzer bis sie schneller wären ab
bis sie langsamer werden dass wirklich
der kreislauf aktiviert wird gern und
ich bin mir ganz sicher
er kennt sich erinnern an unser 1234
spiel der sommer schon zwei mal gemacht
hätte machen was noch drittes mal des
baumarkts aufwärmen mit ein
ich wiederhole name 1 die linke hand
heben zwei rechte hand heben
3 das linke knie heben und vier das
rechte knie heben und das ganze aus dem
lockeren lauf so schnell wie möglich
umsetzen wir fangen wir ganz einfach an
mit 413
so okay jetzt kombinieren hat es wieder
mit 21 24 12 4
also das ist ja cool aus ich hoffe euch
gehts zu hause gleich gut wie meinen
zwei arme auslauf haben stehen bleiben
am tief durchatmen ja das was wir jetzt
machen ist in oberkörper verdrehen das
heißt der platz aufrecht stehen und
schwingt nach links und nach rechts in
den oberkörper einfach hin und her und
schaut dass ihr da bislang beweglichkeit
im bereich der wirbelsäule hineinbringt
hat diese mobilisieren und dann sah man
aber mitten auf wir haben asche wieder
fertig ok jetzt bereit gehen wir es an
wir beginnen mit dem mit der
wadenmuskulatur mit dem zwillings
wadenmuskel das ganze ist bei den
übungen beim springen beim laufen aber
nur springen am montag war das ganz
stark mit dabei
deswegen nehme den jetzt einmal her und
schauen uns an wie man am geschicktesten
training kann ja nehmen eure position
ein bitte ich kann das natürlich
einerseits an einer treppe machen
wichtig ist haltet euch an denen sie zur
gleichgewicht übung werden ja oder kann
das an einer mauer machen wo er den fuß
an stelle
da gibt es mehrere varianten wir haben
wir zwar aber heraus gefasst und ihr
geht es langsam in die ideen position
hinein und wir kommen langsam aus der
position wieder heraus ja das heißt eine
druckfertige mitreißen und des klimas an
30 sekunden ungefähr geht es in den
muskel hinein spürt die muskulatur und
löst es wirken ja atmet banks and as you
to thank sonst denen denkt sonst atmen
und dann kann man wirklich spüren wie
man die spannung aus der muskulatur
verliert
genau seitenwechsel langsam aus der
position kommen langsam in die andere
position hineingehen konzentrieren
spüren was sie bewegt in der muskulatur
wichtig dabei ist des knies gestreckt
dass man schön in den zwillings
wadenmuskel hineinkommen
der oberkörper entspannt aufrecht und
langsam wieder aus der position heraus
kommen
habt ihr zweites glück spürt nik
weisbrod rennen gary trat super die
zweite übung die man machen ist für die
oberschenkel vor der seite das heißt den
krieg selbst das heißt äußerst großer
muskel im oberschenkel drauf ist der
bahnstrecke mit welcher variante käme
das denic jahre
genauso ist es schauen dann wenn die
verse beim gesäß ist dass man eine die
hüfte er leicht nach vorn schiebt das
man wirklich eine schöne spannung in die
muskulatur hineinbringt wer es kann kann
das natürlich auch ohne anhalten machen
und das gleichgewicht auch so halten
wenn das denen aber zugleich gewichts
übung wird und die sowie beim am
mittwoch im training ausgleichen muss
die bewegung da an ist es nicht richtig
ja da muss ich wirklich sicher stehen im
einband stand dann kann ich das auch
ohne anhalten machen aber einfach ist es
sicherlich sich entsprechend irgendwo
anzuhalten so ist er genial macht
ok langsam wieder aus der position
heraus kommen jahre wechselt die seite
und mit der nici zahlreiche weitere
variante im knien der denic gekniet sich
ab nimmt das hintere bein in die hand
schiebt das becken ganz leicht nach vor
so dass sie wieder eine schöne spannung
in der oberschenkel vorderseite bekommt
wichtig ist dass sie hat da eine
aufrechte position hat
und wer seinen fuß nicht ganz gut
erwischt hinten kann natürlich das
anhand durch seine finger seine händler
zu verlängern
dass man da einen schönen zug zusammen
bringt aber rein prinzipiell sollte das
schon möglich sein
genau wie gesagt wichtig beim gary die
oberschenkel sind einigermaßen parallel
nebeneinander und die ferse wird zum
gesäß gezogen ohne dass dabei die hüfte
nach hinten kippt sondern die bleibt
aufrecht und gerade langsam wieder aus
der position heraus kommen und ausloggen
genau wir haben beide seiten erledigt
nach der oberschenkel vor der seite
nehmen wir natürlich gleich die
rückseite den bayern beugen wie macht
man das was gibt's dafür varianten
ja genau etwas erhöht der rücken gerade
die schultern zurückgezogen der
oberkörper aufrecht der kopf wieder in
verlängerung der wirbelsäule und wie
gehen auch vor langsam in die dehnung
hinein
wer das ganze noch ein bisschen
intensivieren möchte der kann jetzt
einfach aus der position so wie er jetzt
steht die zehn richtung knie zurück
ziehen das kann man mit hand
unterstützung machen oder einfach nur
muskulär zurückziehen die höhe des blogs
ist ziemlich egal ob das die tischhöhe
ist die sessel höhe ist ist überhaupt
kein problem
wichtig ist nur das duo aufrecht bleibt
gerne und versuchst nicht entsprechend
dort die beweglichkeit aus dem
oberkörper zu holen sondern eben wie
gesagt aus der muskulatur dabei eine der
arbeit ist langsam den druck
herausnehmen und wieder die seite
wechseln
auch heute ist es natürlich so wenn ihr
fragen zu dem ganzen training habt wenn
ihr fragen habt zum auslaufen zum
regenerieren oder zum training auch
allgemein stellt die fragen schreibt es
hinein kommentiert der post und der
doktor aus wird die fragen gerne
beantworten
genau aufrecht bleiben schöne position
halten das knie ist sauber
durchgestreckt und ihr habt so schöne
spannung in der muskulatur drinnen
langsam wieder herauskommen aus der
position haben wir ausschüttungen den
ganzen körper mit durch bewegen und
damit durchschnitt um die nächste
muskelgruppe die wir heraus fassen ist
der hüftbeuge hat er ganz wichtige
aufgabe bei den ausfall schritten
beispielsweise mit dabei bitte einmal
die position auf der matte wir schauen
uns das an es gibt auch unterschiedliche
varianten
wir nehmen die variante mit dem knie am
boden abgelegt das heißt dass wir vor
nicki wenn du hoch wenn du dich hoch
drückt kann man natürlich auch denen in
der hüftbeuge aber dann wird es mit
einer gewissen zeit zur kraftübungen das
wollen wir heute nicht das heißt wir
legen die das knie am boden ab strecken
die zehn nach hinten aus und versuchen
dass die cs nach vorzuschieben das
becken nach vor zu drücken
schatz dabei das einen geraden
unterschenkel habt dass er nahezu einen
zu großen oder zu kleinen winkel im
kniegelenk der oberkörper bleibt weiter
aufrecht und natürlich und wir sagen
locker in der den position drinnen
je mehr dass ihr euch auf das
konzentriert wo er hin dance desto mehr
könnte da natürlich herausholen aus dem
ganzen workout atmet bleibt kontrolliert
und ganz wichtiger denen sieg ein
schmerzhafter reiz sein das heißt es
nicht weh tun und die kam die frau
lauter schmerzen gar nicht konzentrieren
sondern ein lockeres ziel in der
muskulatur ist gut aber alles was
darüber hinaus geht muss auch nicht sein
langsam bitte wieder aus der position
heraus kommen haben wir aus schütteln
und die zweite seite
genau der hüftbeuger ja ganz wichtige
muskulatur für uns brauche ich bei
vielen sportlichen bewegungen gerade
wenn es ums springen geht ja ums landen
bei den ausfall schritten die knie hub
ist der hüftbeuger immer mit dabei also
da habe ich ganz viele möglichkeiten den
zu trainieren
und das ist eine gute variante ihm zu
regenerieren um die spannung wieder
herauszunehmen nochmal 50 kunden
vorbereiten und langsam bitte wieder aus
der position heraus kommen mehr
aufstehen aus lockern
auch beim regenerationstraining ist es
so dass immer wieder einen schluck
trinken die flüssigkeit zuführen
das ist aber in jedem training abends
locker ist wenn es regenerativ ist eine
wichtige voraussetzung um leistungsfähig
auch zu sein und die letzte übung für
die beine die wir uns jetzt noch
anschauen ist dies also für die beine
für die unteren extremität wo der ball
hinten für mich dazu gehört wir schauen
uns den hintern aber schauen uns die
gesäßmuskulatur hat und das machen wir
sehr angenehmen position nämlich liegend
bitteschön das ist für euch zu hause
legt euch gemütlich auf die matte wir
fangen an streckt die rechte hand vom
körper weg nach außen und zieht das
rechte knie an nehmt die linke hand aufs
knie und dreht es zur seite also wer
meinen worten jetzt nicht ganz folgen
hat können schaut sie am besten die
positionen von der niki oder vom career
und macht das einfach nach
wichtig dabei ist so jetzt nicht mit den
schultern von bodenlos lösen die
schultern bleiben am boden beide ja und
die bewegung kommt denn wie gesagt da
aus dem aus dem bein teilweise aus der
wirbelsäule und gedehnt wird die
gesäßmuskulatur der koleos maximus
entspannen tief durchatmen zur ruhe
kommen
19 sekunden nur
und bevor alles läuft normal langsam
wieder aus der position heraus und
wechseln die seite da auch wieder
langsam in die den position hineingehen
keine ruckartigen bewegungen beim denen
sondern alle bewegungen sind fließend
sind entspannt sind langsam auch hier
keine schmerzen sondern ein lockeres
ziehen in der muskulatur ist erwünscht
aber mehr nicht
genau
die sechs muskulatur brauche bei jeder
bewegung wenn es darum geht mein becken
zu strecken meine hüfte zu strecken da
sparen sie dahinter anja beim becken
geben haben wir das in jeder variante
mit dabei gehabt
ok dann kann man langsam wieder aus der
opposition heraus stets um auf beide
lockert sich aus die nächste bewegung
die man machen geht jetzt eher in den
bereich mobilität hinein das bislang
dynamisch als eine nieder intensive
dynamik mit dabei angeleitet oder
abgeleitet aus dem yoga die übung das
heißt bitte einmal in die position
bauchlage beide legen sich bitte hin
achsen das gelenk darf schon mal sein
die hände wie beim liegestütz unter den
schultern und jetzt schaut sag mal nach
oben gerichtet habe auch versucht die
hände so gut wie es geht durch zu
strecken ja da gibt es auch die variante
muskulär anstrengend das kniegelenk und
den oberschenkel vom boden abheben oder
die lockere variante das ganze abgelegt
nachdem wir es regenerativ machen
bleiben wir abgelegt auf dem boden die
zehen können zurück lang machen
das ist eine variante genau und jetzt
schiebt nach hinten durch sodass ihr wie
in eine pyramide quasi mit eurem körper
kommt und geht 200 mit den händen zurück
schaut eventuell dass er die fersen am
boden auflegen kennst atmen nicht
vergessen und langsam wieder in die
position nach vorkommender wechsel mal
zwei drei mal hin und her
ja sehr schön und wieder zurück in die
pyramide position nach hinten
gerne haben die fersen und die
handflächen da in der position am boden
sind ist das steuer zeichen für eine
sehr hohe beweglichkeit und einmal noch
nach vor wandern durchdrücken und man
spürt auch die spannung in der
bauchmuskulatur wie sie da ist okay
herauslocken langsam aus der position
heraus kommt wenn technik
was macht man auf den oberkörper der
oberkörper seite fordert opfer sein
genau das ist eine übung bietet dafür
bieten dass du uns gern mal vor zeigst
genau hier quasi zusammen wie ein
kleines kind streckt die arme aus und
dann wanderte mit den armen zur seite
bisher einen zug ja hier seitlich in der
muskulatur drinnen spürt das heißt im
rückenmuskeln breiten rückenmuskel da
herunter kommt der zug hinein wenn ihr
die position hat es bleibt sie da
drinnen und versucht sie hier die
spannung loszulassen zu lösen erklärt ua
bitte auch in die position
die zweite variante für diese übung ihr
seht man kann das einem stehen machen
diejenigen von rechte zb ein problem
haben dass sie so am knie arbeiten
machen ihm stehen überkreuzen die beine
und ziehen die eine hand mit der anderen
zur seite und dann habt ihr die perfekte
spannung drinnen so langsam die position
verlassen und die seite wechseln weil er
nicht gesehen sie hat die seite schon
gewechselt die hat es ungefähr ein
gefühl waren die spannung nachlässt
waren die regeneration einsetzt
wie gesagt auch da sollte nicht zu
gleichgewichtsübungen werden sicher
stehen konzentrieren an punkt fixieren
mit den augen
dann funktioniert das im normalfall ganz
gut langsam bitte wieder aus der
position heraus kommen uns wieder
aufrichten aus lockern
die nächste übung die man anbieten ist
eine den übung für den brustmuskel den
haben wir gerade einen breiten
liegestütz gehabt oder aber eine
gesprungenen liegestütz von gary gestern
die er perfekt vorgezeigt hat und
trainiert hat da ist der brustmuskel mit
gefordert und da ist es eine variante
das ganze an einer mauer zu machen oder
auch eine variante maschine absichern
hand durch rolfes zusammen geht in die
arm streckung und lässt die hände so
weit wie möglich nach hinten freund und
dann kommt hier herein dazu im bereich
von brustmuskel wichtig dabei ist haltet
die bauch spannung das heißt ist power
drinnen damit ihnen hohlkreuz hinein
fall dass sie nicht den rücken beleidigt
sondern wirklich nur die brustmuskulatur
däne
und da haben wir noch eine zweite
variante die der kehre euch zeigt an der
mauer
das heißt die kennt man im normalfall er
dort drinnen der jahre hält sich quasi
an der mauer fest und drückt die
schulter rotiert leicht hinein dass er
den zug an der brustmuskulatur spürt
gerne bitte einmal die zweite seite
nicht ich gehe dann mal kurz heraus aus
der spannung lockert einmal durch und
kann auch ein zweites mal pro
muskelgruppe gerne hinein trainieren
okay manchmal noch ein zweites mal
spürbar wie die spannung heraus geht
wäre ja ein wichtiger punkt dass man das
wirklich fühlt und spürt man dann macht
es denen doppel ziehen
ok langsam aus der position wieder
herauskommen
aufstehen aus lockern jetzt haben wir
schon ganz viel abgedeckt wir haben die
beine die gesäßmuskulatur wir waren beim
bauch wir waren beim rücken grunden wir
waren dann rücken seitlich wir haben
schon den brustmuskel seien schon forst
durch mit dem mit unserem körper
das heißt jetzt nehmen wir noch die
schulter heraus die haben wir in vielen
übungen mit belastet die kann auf eine
alt bekannte art und weise ganz gut
trainieren nicht geschaut die variante
aus genau ich strecke eine hand zur
seite greife mit der anderen her und sie
hier den arm quasi zum eigenen körper
her dabei ganz wichtig die schultern
bleiben tief das heißt die bewegung geht
nicht nach oben sondern die bewegung
geht zur seite und die schulterpartie iv
nicht hoch gerne auch da entspannter
kopf der nacken ist gerade und ob wir
jetzt die hand ganz durchstrecken und
geraten leicht mit drinnen habe es macht
keinen großen unterschied erst als beide
male in der dehnung der
schultermuskulatur selber drinnen
ok langsam die position wieder verlassen
die seite wechseln
da aber wiederum in jeder position die
auf recht habe zu denen grundspannung in
der rumpfmuskulatur muss gegeben sein um
entsprechend nicht in ein hohlkreuz
hinein zu fallen sondern derart stabil
und aufrecht zu bleiben dass ich mir
wirklich auf die dehnung konzentrieren
kann und mir nicht im nachhinein an den
rücken anfang zum wedeln und langsam
wieder aus der position heraus kommen
genau jetzt haben wir einige übungen
statisch markt behalten eine übung mit
der bislang national league drinnen mit
einer gewissen mobilisation drinnen ist
macht man auch zum abschluss eine übung
mobilisieren für den nacken und dann
doch eine für die lendenwirbelsäule und
dann sah man mit unserem programm
okay die nackten übung henze die haben
wir zum aufwärmen stark gemacht und das
soll auch zeigen übungen zu mobilisieren
die beim aufwärmen noch kann er
jederzeit in der cooldown programm oder
in ein regeneratives programm einbauen
die bewegungen sind langsam sind
fließend sind nicht hektisch und dann
ist es eine gute variante wie das sowohl
als auch ein bank an
okay wir beginnen mit dem kopf bewegen
von links nach rechts
das war zu einfach haben wir auf die
linke seite vom zimmer voller bewegung
auf die rechte seite der wechsel mal
bäume langsam hin und her versucht sein
zu schauen wie weit das ihr nach hinten
schauen können so dass die schulden aber
der körper stabil bleibt und merkt sich
die position weil vielleicht wird es
dann mit jeder bewegung von links und
rechts schauen dann sogar vielleicht an
zentimetern mehr weil das geht relativ
rasch ok nächste variante wir kippten
den kopf von der linken auf die rechte
seite
und wir schauen nach oben und wir
schauen nach unten dass das team geht
zur brust und das team geht nach oben
dawkins einen stand immer wieder
kontrollieren stehe ich sie verstehe ich
gut sind meine schultern aktiv bin in
einer ordentlichen aufrechten position
oder bin ich etwas zusammengefallen
korrigiert sich da immer wieder und kam
auf die linke seite und rollen
das kinn über die brust zur rechten
seite und das thema bäume hin und
herrollen genau letzte variante für die
nackenmuskulatur stellt sich hin schaut
sie mal geradeaus dann kippt er den kopf
auf die rechte seite stellt die linke
hand auf und zieht es langsam mit dem
kopf in die richtung hinein wobei nicht
bitte mit der hand unterstützt sondern
einfach nur den kopf zur seite liegt
sondern kriegt sich hier in der
nackenmuskulatur unter einen schönen
lockeren zug der zum regenerieren dieser
muskulatur absolut ausreichend ist und
dann bitte noch mal die seite wechseln
ruhig weiteratmen konzentrieren und
langsam wieder aus der opposition heraus
kommen
okay was für uns nur in unserer liste
was dir dass du noch kernmarken die
lendenwirbelsäule mobilisieren
das schauen wir uns jetzt auf zwei
unterschiedliche varianten an die nicht
gezeigt euch die variante mit knie
geschlossen
das heißt hier stützt hinten ab setzt
euch hin stützt euch ab und lässt beide
beine gleich nach links und nach rechts
langsam hinunter was die beweglichkeit
hat so hergibt und wechselte hin und her
und die zweite variante die euch der
kirche zeigt ist die beine sind geöffnet
und wer macht es aber die ganz die
gleiche bewegung ja das heißt nach links
und nach rechts und dargelegt so schöne
mobilisieren mobilisation im bereich der
lendenwirbelsäule hinein um dort ist
auch die spannung und den druck heraus
zu bekommen
genau wie kannst du schon was sagen wie
fühlt sich das im vergleich zum anfang
an bist du entspannter bist du muskulär
wieder besser unterwegs
auf jeden fall nutzt die zeit macht die
macht diese regeneration genauso weil in
der regenerationsphase kann der körper
sich entwickeln in der belastungsphase
wird er quasi schwächer und in der
regeneration entwickelt dass sie und
jeder stärker das ist wegen des aus los
dann nehme mir ganz viel von meinen
trainingserfolg server weg ok danke
schön für das vorzeigen der dankeschön
geht das war der freitag das war das
letzte werk hat für diese woche
danke dass ihr so zahlreich mit dabei
war der erfolg daran beteiligt ja wir
also da gibt uns recht wir verlängern
das ganze um eine woche das heißt
nächste woche sind wir zur gleichen zeit
um 10 uhr 30 gerne wieder für euch da
mit entsprechenden workouts wir machen
auch ein wunsch workout das heißt ihr
könnt gerne das video kommentieren mit
eurem wunsch workout was wir nächste
woche mit euch gemeinsam machen werden
das heißt entweder der intermittierende
rumpf kraft zirkel vom montag dass kraft
ausdauertraining das militärisch
fitnessprogramm also was wir die ganze
woche angeboten haben was er gern in
einer abgewandelten form noch einmal
trainieren würde
hinterlasst seine kurze nachricht dann
können wir das gerne mit einbauen und
eine kleinigkeit fabiano nachdem die
anfrage gekommen ist ja wir haben diese
sensationellen trinkflaschen ja und wir
werden dort pro tag drei stück verlosen
als kleine erinnerung als dankeschön
dass ihr damit der bei bartz und das
einzige was ihr dafür tun müsst teil zu
unserem weil zum sowieso video und
kommentiert das video und dann satz mit
dabei dann wahllos mal pro tag wie
gesagt drei erinnerungs trinkflaschen ja
das war es von meiner seite ich wünsche
euch ein schönes wochenende nutzt die
zeit trainiert regeneriert wie auch
immer wir sehen uns am montag um 10 uhr
30 dankeschön dass dabei war